spring and Michael Wilbon pardon the
interruption celebrating 15 years
Michael congratulations thanks for
joining us dan thank you very much
appreciate that are you in for more
replay or would you like to have less
replay or keep it as it is no I'm about
the same on replay I just heard you
talking about explanations and I'm
always in favor of more of that I just
think you know I mean if umpires are
paid to do this job and that includes
referees in the NFL and NBA as well just
make people available you know and it's
all less sinister of you just able to
say to somebody hey what what happened
there I mean even I remember I remember
situation where i was at the game you
know what you and I might have been at
this game together remember the game
where Joey Crawford through Tim Duncan
out for laughing at him and we were able
to just say to Joey Joey did you talk
him for the laughing and do he goes yeah
ya did ok you know it wasn't Watergate
it was just you'd like to get
explanation who you know why was Adrian
cazal now that I I think the explanation
could really reduce the need for more
replay I don't really see the need for
more replay in any sport did you think
Gonzalez was out um you know I'm you
know I'm biased I got a horse in the
race I thought he's probably safe okay
but you know I but we see those calls
every night where people miss important
strike call and then the guy hits a home
run on the next pitch which happened to
you know Arrieta the previous night we
you know people miss call to the plate
and replay get some wrong I'm interested
now in this whole notion that there
should be somebody who's not an umpire
making these things I didn't think of
that because what they're protecting the
guys on the field they don't want to
show them up maybe I mean you're gonna
find some Syrian wherever yeah but I
thought that one I didn't I didn't think
of until I heard of this morning the
Dodgers making a mistake by not going
with Kirsch on tonight no I think they
think they have a handle on it and and
you know we don't know what the
conversations are between Kershaw and
the pitching coaches manager and the
trainer everybody wanted to make fun of
Dave Roberts I was one of them who said
before I asked a trainer and people say
i think it was great i don't know who it
was Pete Rose
who said well suppose the trainer said
don't go what do you listen to him and
maybe the answer is yes so you know I
mean pitching he if he pitches like five
times in 10 days harder that's sort of
the same you know I mean they got
somebody else and you could make the
argument either way you do you pitch
them tonight and hope to get to 32 and
then you know but then you gotta pitch
maida anyway um and probably I don't
know if the game six is game seven
depending on when you try to use hill if
there is a game seven so I think this
any good Dodgers have a good grasp on
this and understand what it is you know
they need from the rest of their club in
addition in addition to the god of of
starting pitching can you imagine a life
after the Cubs win a title uh you know
damn is funny arm I've never thought
about it but today the truth my son and
my eight-year-old son said to me he's
become uh you know he's a he's a company
was in Washington primarily but he's you
know he's got hooked on this and I'll he
was about three years old and he was
going these cup games and bud silly
bussli said to my wife don't let Michael
do this to yourself no idiot that's a
bud you were a cup in your whole life
because I know I love him peace people
forget that but on the brutal walkie
franchise the buds of Chicago in and
rooting for the Cubs it's not know I
know you're right it looked at her and
said listen to me don't don't let don't
let him do this to your son and and
that's sort of no no matter how much you
love them that's you know this conundrum
you Libya with this franchise and so
that same son is now eight years old and
he said to me the other day when he
would he I took him out of school to go
to a playoff game that's how twisted I
probably on them and he said dad you
gonna cry if the Cubs win and I said I
don't know are you gonna cry if they
lose this is possibility yeah yeah I'm
crying already a law that at that
happens I was eight years old are you
kidding me and you're so bad I've never
thought about what the what is are they
going to be less lovable if they win I
other Red Sox less popular no they're
not less populated 13 times so I don't
think so well my son became all in red
sock family the year
403 he come back he became a Red Sox fan
so he came home said I'm a Red Sox fan I
go oh god no don't do that you had the
blood feeling react yeah but then he
said no dad they're gonna win I said
dough there have been you know fathers
and grandfathers who've never send them
when he said you know get ready for the
long haul and then he goes in boom yeah
man they win yeah and I he was long
suffering for a year like poor poor kid
you guys are celebrating your 15th year
did it did pti almost not happen nothing
I know of I mean it almost not happen in
the Tony and I didn't believe it was
going to happen and didn't really care
if it happened was it successful right
away where we are the rating with you if
you judge it by ratings sure I remember
them telling us about reading now i
really don't i'm still a newspaper guy
in that way uh they said something like
if you get a point three will keep you
on the air if you get a point for we're
going to be reasonably happy to get a
point five you know we're going to carry
you around in chairs and of course they
didn't and then it got up to a point
eight relatively quickly and so it was
double it was almost triple what they
thought to keep us on the air double
what they thought they'd be happy with
and so if you judge the success by that
i guess i guess so but there's almost
not happen I don't know it wasn't long
in the work Stan I mean Mark Shapiro
took me to dinner when that in la during
the NBA finals and said I want to put
this on the air this is like the day
after he was named Czar of programming
or whatever entitled might have been a
nice i'm gonna put it on the air and
that's my first act and i said the
second act is to fire you can put into
sports writers on the air but that but
there wasn't it wasn't like there were
any backroom dealings and negotiations
and I want this it was like what what
are you talking about I mean you know
you one of the people I've said too what
what what is what do you think of this
and I think people had a lot I think
people were a lot more encouraged about
the notion of it than Tony and I were
well I i remember a kornheiser asked me
about he goes can you believe they're
he's walking around with John Walsh
and he goes can you believe they're
giving us a TV show and I remember
telling you as long as they allowed you
to be you yeah yeah remember you can
play and if you got to do that then that
because that's that's the brilliance of
pti is you guys can have an opinion you
can root for a team you can dislike a
commissioner you know even though we
have relationships or had relation rate
all the rules yes we pray we do and you
got I remembered literally that sentence
come out of your mouth multiple times
and that they did they did and and I
think part of that too is tony and i
have to listen to people like you would
been around the bristol culture for a
long time a few other people said the
same they said listen if they're not
going to be you don't do it and we
understood that we we got least we got
that right away but i still didn't think
I just remember thinking you know this
is crazy but but but after we were on
the air a couple of months I thought you
know what the network doesn't have this
was at the time it didn't have opinion
yes and this is gonna this is gonna be
fine well we tried to account years but
we were trying to do it under the veil
of secrecy Keith and I where you could
have an opinion but you were doing it
late at night hoping that management was
not staying up because you guys were at
five Eastern and management of course is
still awake and someone were and they're
listening to this opinion where you're
calling out a commissioner of a league
that they have a relationship or a
kosher yeah you know that and there were
topics I mean Tony got in trouble but he
didn't get it in trouble on pti right
they know that was radio the traffic
mrs. radio but we were we were calling
you know Dan that's a great point I mean
I remembers we early on the show women
bud would win but Felix who we both love
would just not talk about so publicly
like like you could always officer the
city talk to you for an hour but he
wouldn't talk publicly yes it's only I
kept saying hey bud get out from under
your desk and it was and at the time I
you know that's not you know the height
of criticism now but at the time I guess
in 2001 it was and bud called both of us
and said okay enough enough I'll come on
and even after we screaming at him to
come out from under the desk and he came
on it was great and it was different in
any
he even said at the time you know put
the pressure on people that there
haven't been that we can't imagine
that's only 15 years old that kind of
criticism that says you know step up
here open your mouth well you Tony's
done that with Adam Silver the
Commission in the NBA if you because
that person doesn't actually go and talk
to Adam so who's available to talk
probably anytime and I do and you you
called out Goodell before all the time
and I and I'm I'm actually I'm actually
i'm proud to say but i will say i'm
gonna toot the horn to this extent i was
doing this years ago before we got to
you know domestic violence issues and
things of that were that level of
seriousness i just bought the Roger
Goodell who I knew got to know
reasonably well when I was covered in FL
for years that he was a different guy
that the guy we see now is not the Roger
Goodell who I thought was uniquely
qualified to be the commissioner I don't
see that guy anymore and so that's what
I was calling out what happened to that
guy that then you read stories later
that he's shoving you know his
supervisor of officials I mean really
what with that guy come from because
that's not the guy who everybody thought
was going to make a great commissioner
so yeah I think it's our job to do that
as we do as we did in our columns in the
newspaper in the washington post as we
would do in the green room I mean I you
know one thing about we're not scared
anybody and if they want to get angry
about it and come back at us they got a
phone to do that well congrats and good
luck to your Cubs Mike we need all the
well wishes we can get mr. Patrick thank
you for that are the Indians a better
story this year though than your Cubs
Mike there are there as good a story as
anybody because of the peak of the
city's situation not to franchise but
the city I mean given it what LeBron
started off there and yeah I'm sure
you've had Terry Francona obviously he
he speak to that so eloquently about the
sort of the momentum and the way the
city feels about itself and the people
there feel about themselves in the
aftermath of the LeBron championship and
so I think they're a great story I look
not as many people care about the
Indians as the cups yeah when you go to
an Indian's road game you don't have
15,000 people
err rooting for the Indians you just
don't have that plea was not Chicago and
I say that at yes I'm a Chicago but I
also traveling up and go to game soon
enough do you see the the number of Cub
fans they can show it at Dodgers Los
Angeles I no no no all right well you're
going to be all with it there a better
story you're going to be crying win or
lose yeah I'm apparently so thank you my
apparently Baghdad all right Mike Wilbon
will be the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience